these are the people on facebook who
need to shut up the liberal hippie girl
the police organization sanctioned to
oppress us by our government and we're
just supposed to take that the
ultra-conservative guy thing is if you
give them welfare you incentivize them
to work and the guy who thinks they're
both wrong okay america was never
supposed to be a two-party system that's
why we need ron paul girls who post
party pics there's nothing wrong with it
except for the fact it's the same
pictures every weekend and then it gets
really weird when you see this guy your
friend from eighth grade he's closer to
his 30s yet he keeps partying with 19
year olds
then there's this girl
the workout enthusiast she just posts
pictures of her nice fit body we get it
you're hot parents who are obsessed with
their kids you post a bunch of pictures
that it's annoying what's more annoying
is people who complain about parents who
are obsessed with their kids you are the
worst and then there's this guy just
wanted to let you all know that my
grandma died the pity seeker uh also my
dog died and i'm not looking for your
sympathy i'm more looking for a date
because i'm single you know what's even
worse than the pity seeker see this car
the [ __ ]
show off
new promotion i know i know i know
it's pretty awesome
i'm getting married
your ex-girlfriend
i should have given you that ring the
person who keeps promising they're gonna
change i've learned my lesson guys i
swear to god never ever partying again
he doesn't mean it not at all the guy
who thinks facebook is his own stand-up
comedy show and if you don't think he's
funny he's gonna hit you with this now
i'm not really sure that's your you
would get it it's a little meta and i'm
not sure suck dude and worst of them all
you suck oh my god the guy who's too
cool for facebook he hates on everything
about it yet he's still on it
you suck